[Musique]
ali toungara bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin dans la matinale de rtl
france alors on va on va le voir sur des
images à suivre il ya eu encore des
manifestations hier antilles françaises
à bamako alors ce sentiment là est ce
que c'est
isolé ou alors est-ce que c'est très
partagé dans la population malienne ce
que le sport les gars de cette montée du
sentiment anti politique mais l'itf ans
et d'aller salomé liam un particulier
l'épisode de ce sentiment est partagé
par nombre important les sahéliens
particulier des maliens messieurs qu'il
faut quand même relativiser le sentiment
aujourd'hui on peut beaucoup de pilotes
française des voiliers en solo de n'est
pas pour estomper
comme elle l'avait promis en 2013
l'expansion de l'offre terroristes à
l'aisselle mais le contamine peu de
clients depuis des voix se font entendre
et qui sait lesquels voient cet hommage
c'est la pertinence et surtout sur la
nécessité du maintien est offensé
zoomania s'ils voulaient garder les
secteurs commencé dès les raisons du non
qui m'a bien 2000 pour l'accueil c'est
aujourd'hui à gagner non seulement les
centres du pile comment les réseaux
notice et vous même une bonne partie
également des chiffres de la raison
d'état et donc tout cela laisse entendre
aujourd'hui elle tous les militaires et
logistiques à la france un des pics tous
- les coûteuses les geeks avec cogolin
compte une série d'allégations de
qualité donc pour vous la présence
militaire française a pour effet pervers
si ce que dira d'envenimer finalement le
cette question des terroristes dans le
sahel et que pensez vous du retrait
justement qui qui semble s'amorcer ce
qu'il faut de cannes unleashing avec ce
sentiment un diplôme technique française
la fin se remplit une fonction vitale
pour le facv sept militaires de dessiner
même des maliens mais je pense que c'est
qu'il poursuit concurrence aujourd'hui
sa façon d'opérer
si vous ne deviez l'édifiante victoire
qui sont emportés par la force basque
anne françaises sont quand même des
victoires isolées elles n'ont pas
associé clément effectivement les
zanessa im dans ce qui le touche
également la france
des délestages c'est le fait que les
mots qui sont exprimés explicitement
dans les années signalement notamment
elle demande à ce qu'il soit voté et par
des moyens logistiques opa de moins à y
ait pas d appeler le permet il à
permettait fourni des rations des
politiques et leurs instruments mais
malheureusement en dépit des six -
clairement précédémment clairement
formulée
la france a porté tous les instruments
terre la france beaucoup d'hôpitaux une
nouvelle cartographie scénique
distractives ce sont ces actions qui
sont les prochaines sinon les
consentements et la france a permis aux
maquilleurs et 2013 avant jeudi
d'assists a cédé 8 à calmer et il s'est
quand même plus dans les semaines à
venir qu'ils aient les moyens de le
faire en sorte que les armées syrienne
real mais française puis ça les a menés
vouliez sous un commandement commun ici
quand même par temps l'épisode macau
rappelé la mission rp connerie est mort
qui assure un stage de formation à
l'endroit des forces israéliennes de
voir sa façon d'agir avec cette fois ci
elle n'a même pas son sac à main
chaque pays européen à ces approches ces
méthodes bout justement une sur deux
confie division ou avec un final au
terme du cycle mention dissipant les
admise affectionne justement ali
tounkara
est ce que la population pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est désormais alarmées
sait
malienne pardon aux militaires maliens
finalement d'assurer la sécurité la
lutte contre le terrorisme dans la zone
du sahel
oui mon objectif la même année c'est la
mesure qui n'est pas me gillot ce temps
de combattre ces groupes radicaux
violents
cette finale mais celles qui restent
engagés se veut différente chaque
population mais était tout comme des
sites est évidente autant et du point de
vue des formations du point de vue
logistique même en inde un mordu du
moral des troupes et mais pas sans
savoir qu'avec le président yves
hectares et qui a été déchiré vraiment
d'autres passé et avait quand même ma
mort c'est l'effarement c'est qu'on
appelle la loi de programmation
militaire lesquelles réformes à tout le
monde elle lui a vidé les autres pays en
lutte et un gain partis et des taux
n'est pas une partie de la gamme suit
donc vouloir aujourd'hui dès que la
malienne est en mesure de sécuriser
l'ensemble territoire et les utiliser
des potées et donne surtout et les
populations quoi ce volonté politique
justement le fait que de rendre cette
armée malienne plus opérationnels ça
passe par une réelle volonté politique
elle existe aujourd'hui avec le nouveau
pouvoir en place avec les autorités
militaires des bulles d'aidé de l'état
aujourd'hui incontestablement en eau
sable sous les les
un certain déplacement quand même a de
plus en plus les actions militaires tous
les thés loire depuis dans glee les
efforts militaires et intel suffisamment
de l'édition actuelle est-elle
suffisamment et les jeux molécules dont
chanceux et la volonté l'éclaircie avec
l'esprit des militants mais il faut les
longtemps bien former davantage les
ambitions d'une audition de tableau
permet d'aller dispenser des fondations
il s'obstine t décidément c
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup ali
toungara d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
je le rappelle vous êtes directeur
fondateur du centre des études
sécuritaires et stratégiques au sahel et
vous êtes à bamako fois